et les chroniqueurs ils ont voulu
refaire les clips des années 2000 on
voulait passer
on voulait faire notre top 4 des
meilleurs clips des années 2000 on
voulait dépasser et puis après on a
téléphoné pour avoir les prix des clips
et très vite j'ai dit est ce que ce
serait pas plus simple de les retourner
et on m'a dit on a pris notre petit
calculatrice on l'a fait les comptes ont
à dire ah oui c'est moins cher ne les
retourne et donc qu'est ce qu'on a fait
on a pris les chroniqueurs et on a
refait les clips des années 2000
regarder alors moi je veux raconter aux
vaches qui font mal à supporter qui m'a
dicté mais comme m'a dit aimer leur
apporter
[Musique]
ouais gros on va mais ça blesse
allez pas
wallon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci autres liqueurs bravo maxime très
bonne chose et qui font pas assez